THANK YOU.
>> Laura: JOINING US NOW FOR
INSTANT REACTION IS
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM, MEMBER
OF THE HOUSE AND -- EXCUSE ME, I
ALWAYS THINK OF YOU AS THE HOUSE
IMPEACHMENT MANAGER.
SO YOU HEARD A TIDBIT THERE,
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION?
>> A VERY IMPORTANT STATEMENT
THAT SOUTH KOREA, JAPAN AND THE
UNITED STATES.THE SUMMIT WENT
WELL AND WORK TOGETHER BEHIND
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
NOW IF MY DEMOCRATIC FRIENDS
MIGHT GET BEHIND
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WE MAY ACTUALLY
GET A PEACE DEAL.
WE LENT SOME OF THEM ARE
PROGRESSIVE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
AND THEY HAVE COME OUT, KIND OF
SHOCKING, AND SOME OF THEM FOR
THE IMPEACHMENT OF TRUMP.
THEY THOUGHT, LET'S GIVE PEACE A
CHANCE.
A LOT OF THE REAL CRITICISM
COMMENTS FROM CHUCK SCHUMER OR
OTHER REPUBLICANS, SOMETIMES
THEY THROW YOU IN THAT MIX.
BUT I SAY THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> I'M A BIG FAN OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE INHERITED A PROBLEM THAT'S
BEEN BUILDING FOR 30 YEARS,
THERE'S NO PLACE FOR HIM TO KICK
THE CAN.
20 YEARS AGO THEY DIDN'T HAVE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS AND NOW THEY
HAVE A BUNCH.
THEY HAVE A MISSILE THAT COULD
HIT NORTH AMERICA AND IF THEY
MARRY THE TWO UP, WE ARE IN
TROUBLE.
HE'S BEEN SAYING, I'M NOT GOING
TO LET NORTH KOREA HAVE A
MISSILE THAT COULD HIT US.
THAT'S A NONSTARTER.
I WILL OFFER THEM A DEAL THAT
THEY CAN'T REFUSE OR SHOULD
REFUSE.
COMPLIMENTS TO THE PRESIDENT.
I HAVE A BROTHER WHO HAS LIVED
IN KOREA FOR MANY YEARS, AND
HE'S STILL THERE.
HE SAID GATHERED AROUND A LITTLE
VALID VILLAGES, PEOPLE ARE
RIVETED.
LIKE EVERY SHOPKEEPER HAD A
TELEVISION ON.
HE SAID, LET ME TELL YOU.
TO THE SOUTH KOREAN PEOPLE, THIS
IS LIKE GORBACHEV AND REAGAN.
THIS IS POSITIVE DEVELOPMENTS IN
THEIR LIVES BECAUSE THEY HAVE
FAMILIES AND NORTH KOREA.
THEY WANT TO HAVE DIFFERENT
SCENARIOS NOT JUST FOR PEACE AND
SAFETY BUT FOR THEIR CULTURE.
THEY ARE A VERY PROUD PEOPLE.
>> THEY THERE ARE OVER 2 ML
>> THEY THERE ARE OVER 2 MI
>> THEY THERE ARE OVER 2 MN
KOREAN AMERICAN FAMILIES.
PRESIDENT AND I HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THIS AND HE WOULD ONLY
HAVE A WAR IF HE HAD TO.
BUT THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE A
DECISION, HE'S NOT GOING TO
CONTAIN A NUCLEAR ARMED
NORTH KOREA BECAUSE THEY WILL
SELL WHAT THEY BUILD.
HE WILL BRING THE PROGRAM TO END
IN A WINNING WAY.
BUT DEMOCRATS, I ASK YOU ONE
THING.
TELL THE WORLD, NORTH KOREA AND
CHINA, THAT IF DIPLOMACY FAILS
BECAUSE THEY PLAY THE SAME OLD
GAMES, ALL OPTIONS ARE ON THE
TABLE AND GET BEHIND
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Laura: AT RAND PAUL SAYS
YOU ARE A DANGER TO THE WORLD
BECAUSE HE SAID THAT.
BUT OF COURSE AREN'T MILITARY
OPTIONS ALWAYS ON THE TABLE?
>> IF NOT WE WILL NEVER GET A
DEAL, I NEVER WANT TO USE IT.
THE BEST WAY TO GET PIECES TO
CONVINCE NORTH KOREA WE WILL
HAVE A WAR THAT THEY CAN'T WIN.
TRUMP IS DOING EVERYTHING HE
KNOWS HOW TO AVOID A WAR AND I
WOULD BEG NORTH KOREA AND CHINA
TO TAKE HIM UP ON IT.
>> Laura: IT JUST CAME OUT
BEFORE YOU CAME ON THAT THE
PENTAGON IS EXPECTED TO CANCEL
THE AUGUST MILITARY EXERCISES
WITH SOUTH KOREA.
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT THAT OR
IS IT TO SOON TO CANCEL?
>> IF THE PRESIDENT CALLED ME
ON AIR FORCE ONE AND HE SAID,
LET THEM KNOW I'M SERIOUS.
I'M WILLING TO STAND DOWN TO
GIVE THEM THE SPACE THEY NEED TO
MAKE AN INTELLIGENT DECISION.
WE CAN ALWAYS PUT THE EXTRA SIZE
BACK ON SCHEDULE BUT THIS MAY BE
THE LAST BEST CHANCE IN OUR
LIFETIME FOR PEACE.
THIS IS A BULL MOVE FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
WE WILL NOT WITHDRAW OUR FORCES,
AND WE WILL GIVE NORTH KOREA A
SIGN AND BREATHING SPACE.
TO THOSE WHO CRITICIZE THE
PRESIDENT, HOW WELL DID YOU DO
IN NORTH KOREA?
>> Laura: SO YOU CRITICIZE
THEM FOR HOW MUCH IT COST TO DO
THESE INTERVIEWS.
I WATCHED YOU THE OTHER NIGHT, I
DO MY RESEARCH ON YOU.
YOU SAID IT WAS RIDICULOUS TO
QUESTION HOW MUCH MONEY IT
COSTS.
BUT I KIND OF LIKE THE FACT THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS ALWAYS WORRIED
ABOUT THE TAXPAYER MONEY,
WHETHER IT'S MONEY THAT WE GIVE
OVERSEAS TO COUNTRIES THAT TRASH
OUTS, OR -- I'M NOT SAYING
THAT'S NOT IMPORTANT.
BUT I THINK MOST PEOPLE ARE
LIKE, GOOD, HE'S LOOKING OUT FOR
OUR MONEY.
>> THE NUMBER ONE JOB FOR THOSE
IN THE CONGRESS AND THE
PRESIDENT FOR THE MILITARY TO
GIVE THE TRAINING AND EQUIPMENT
THEY NEED, BUT, THAT'S SOMETHING
WE DON'T HAVE TO FIGHT.
>> Laura: IT'S INCREDIBLE
>> Laura: IT'S INCREDIBLE I
>> Laura: IT'S INCREDIBLE C
>> Laura: IT'S INCREDIBLE E
>> Laura: IT'S INCREDIBLE I
>> Laura: IT'S INCREDIBLE L
>> Laura: IT'S INCREDIBLE Y
IMPORTANT AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
28,000 HOMES.
>> IF WE PULLED THAT OUT, CHINA
WOULD MAKE THE SOUTH CHINA SEA.
AND THEY ARE BEGINNING TO BACK
OFF.
IF YOU PLAY TRUMP, YOU MET WITH
HIM, YOU SHOOK HIS HAND AND TOLD
HIM HE WANTED TO GIVE UP YOUR
NUKES FOR A GOOD DEAL.
IF YOU PLAY THIS GUY, YOU WILL
REGRET IT.
THIS IS NOT BARACK OBAMA.
>> LOOK AT POOR JUSTIN, THAT WAS